digital africa ou le fiasco d'un soft
power à la française en afrique voilà
comment on pourrait évoquer une idée
plutôt alléchante à l'origine est
soutenu par dix organisations issues des
deux côtés de la méditerranée
un projet qui se présentait comme une
communauté de partenaires au service des
entreprises numériques africaines
objectif affiché aider les jeunes
pousses du continent à concrétiser leurs
ambitions
emmanuel macron annoncé même en 2018
une dotation de 65 millions d'euros pour
ce programme
j'appelle tous les entrepreneurs
africains de tous les pays du continent
à se joindre à cette initiative des
tutelles africa et joindre la plateforme
depuis six mois un travail important a
été fait avec l' agence française de
développement que je remercie et l'afd
va déployer dans les prochaines semaines
un instrument spécifique doté de 65
millions d'euros pour lancer
l'initiative mais qui va être destiné à
combler cette faille de l'accompagnement
par des petits tickets mais qui sont
ceux dans ces startups ont besoin de
trente à cinquante mille euros
la première phase et qui va accompagner
les projets qui seront sélectionnés sur
la plateforme digitale africa rapidement
l'application revendique une communauté
de 6000 entrepreneurs locaux
mais des divergences sont apparues au
fur et à mesure que le projet avance et
les membres africains critique des choix
qui valorise la mise en réseau plus que
les programmes eux mêmes le rôle du
principal financeur l' agence française
de développement est pointé du doigt
le conseil a été constamment contourner
et rarement informés obtenant la plupart
de ces informations par le biais
d'annoncés sur les réseaux sociaux les
voix des trois membres africains du
conseil d'administration qui ensemble
représentent une communauté de plus d'un
million d'entrepreneurs africains sont
ignorés les problèmes s'enchaînent
plusieurs membres du conseil jette
l'épongé
des démissions en cascade qui mettent en
péril des activités lens
et les capacités de travail de
l'association et alors que beaucoup
croient le projet enterré une période
transitoire de trois à cinq mois destiné
à reformer l'association est décidé
nathalie yang femme politique
camerounaise il voit simplement une
continuité de la françafrique
la france ne considèrera jamais les
africains comme des partenaires jamais
pour eux nous ne sommes que les
habitants de ces colonies de l'espoir à
la désillusion
africa digital a surtout fait ressurgir
des rancoeurs du passé et il n'est pas
sûr qu'une simple refonte de
l'association suffisent à effacer ce
sentiment